good morning everybody oh yeah
Meg looked at a cut seat looked at a cut
and said my God please it's actually not
for weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks
well guys
Mara good morning good morning to uh
start us off here now why do you feel do
you feel compelled to sit in because we
talked so all over the map I want to
avoid wrestling and rock and roll today
if we can
um yeah you know it just I know those
are two pretty cool then they get your
hairs up a bit
um yeah I think you know just we were
missing Meg a little bit in the last I'm
no Megan Ganz no Megan Ganz never will
be but the next best thing you guys have
so to a Wrangler yeah
well that begs a few questions for me
do we think that that was not a
successful podcast I know that it wasn't
a successful conversation about the
episode but does that mean that it
wasn't a successful episode I don't know
no I do think that is uh was a
successful episode I think we we got in
some good topics you guys got fiery
which was delightful
um so we had a follow-up conversation
about this I I I'm starting to believe
that I that I have
maybe maybe issues with social cues or
something because I don't know what
you're talking about Glenn texted me
yesterday was like man that was really
fun and I was like that was fun that was
great and he was like I love it when we
get a little contentious and I was like
well no you wouldn't be intentious but
Glenn was getting hot he was getting
defensive and back in a corner about his
supplements and surely you picked up on
that well yes but about about like uh I
know it was about diet stuff is that
what you're talking about whatever
sleep diet it was the whole today what
you eat approach to and Wilson to your
research and science uh and uh how I
view it versus how he views it yeah well
like in an inability for self-reflection
so
[Music]
pick a link man am I self-reflecting too
much am I thinking about it so basically
are you telling me that you didn't pick
up on this side yeah I do pick up on
that but the difference is that it
doesn't make me feel uncomfortable
that didn't make me feel uncomfortable
either I thought it was delightful
that's that I find it delightful so yeah
so then it doesn't feel contentious to
me but yes I do recognize that he's
defensive I can see that he's he's
getting hot already well it doesn't feel
good to get picked on does it
no no it doesn't it does but for the
sake of for the sake of Show Business
you know it's it's fun now if you guys
keep up this this type of Rhythm our Mac
and Dennis gonna break up
I love
this episode
you're gonna say I love a good segue I
don't love it uh do you want to set it
up for us more absolutely today we'll be
discussing season five episode nine Mac
and Dennis break up
it aired on November 12 2009 it was
written by Scott marter and Rob Rozelle
and directed by Fred Savage
do you feel as though you're like a
little bit like on The Chopping Block
like we're we're like you better get
your rhythms right here kind of the way
you were just looking at me was like
don't [__] this up
I know I was getting like see it's all
it's a lot of judgment that comes from
these two guys
we demand Excellence right right we
don't always achieve Excellence but we
demand it and strive for it so yeah but
I demand Excellence too and then you
come at me about it
you know I demand Excellence for my body
and my yeah and my health yeah yeah you
know so it's like pics pick it which is
it I know you know it's true true if you
were that in depth about you know
something show business related you know
like the the types of cameras or
whatever I wouldn't give a [__] but
right you'd be like that's cool
you got to an eight or nine and you
weren't able to take in the information
that we were the I was I I wasn't no I
just disagreed with it I think he did a
good job by the way okay I just
disagreed with it but that's okay
that's all right you know that's all
part of the deal
you know that's what happens
that's what happens when you get into uh
you know conversations about uh no I
haven't had enough coffee today guys I
tell you what if I had a a bunch of
coffee this morning
and you know I was having a little bit
of a Charlie tummy day which I hadn't
had in a while Charlie tell me yeah it
was just like a little off and I was
like you know what maybe you don't need
that extra cup of coffee did someone
take some cheese into something you ate
yesterday yeah I think there was some
traveling and there was some dabbling
some dabbling with some oils and some
creams and some dairies that I I
normally would avoid and uh and you know
I thought I got away with it and it's
not
and that's
come you know like it doesn't it doesn't
happen that day like it's like two days
later it's like hey man remember
remember me I'm still in here I'm still
in here I'm still a problem I've just
been waiting to come out and like and
how you feel the oils you fed me the
oils
you think you're some kind of oil eating
cheese Monger you ain't you ain't let me
show you you wish you were
yeah well we've now discovered that uh
vegetable oils are are often rancid and
uh you know so it toxic I had a
vegetable juice this morning
I'm talking about vegetable oils now
oh gotta be careful with the vegetable
oils they're rancid I love it but you're
100 right I am because some I'll go to a
restaurant and I'll eat a food that I
normally eat and it's fine for me yeah
but then I'll feel like crap after I'm
like I can tell it was cooked with some
kind of oil that my body's like I don't
know what to do with this because they
cook it they cook it with the cheaper
oils they're cooking it with like
safflower oil or sunflower oil so Glenn
when you go to a restaurant do you ask
like what kind of okay no all right just
because I I I can't I can't that this is
yeah
right so one of the reasons why I think
we're so successful as a group is we
have aspects of our personalities that
complement each other
to form a pretty well-functioning uh
human being you know who can like make a
good TV show whatever it is yeah like if
I could have a little bit of of your
discipline in terms of like knowing what
each type of food is like you don't need
it like you could probably eat whatever
and be fine I probably need your
knowledge so if you could lend your
knowledge to me I don't want it but if
you could if you could just download it
into my brain I don't want to sit and
listen to it at all but if you could
yeah yeah yeah if you could just have it
if I could just have it not have to
actually go through it
but I mean I don't give people the wrong
impression look I had I had uh I had
pizza and chicken wings last night okay
so don't don't you know I don't want
people to think that like I don't that I
all I eat is like you know that I'm
strict about every single thing I'm not
I'm just I'm just knowledgeable about it
I like to be knowledgeable about it
just to be clear I I didn't I was not so
I was not coming down on you about in
fact I pray I praised you for
how much time effort and energy you put
into lots of things all I was suggesting
was that it was it's fascinating how you
will go from zero to ten on something
and then three weeks later when when new
information comes out you go zero to ten
in the opposite direction I haven't done
that in a long time I know but I was
pointing I was pointing back in the past
where that happened that's why I was a
passionate young man you know it's
passionate about my health and I did try
being vegan for a while
um and uh it just didn't work it just
didn't it didn't feel good I didn't like
the food I I didn't feel as well as I
thought it was you know so I've tried
I've tried different things and like
that stupid Master Cleanse which God
we're all trying new things and I and I
think that's admirable like if you came
in and said I'm doing this weird thing
I'm trying it I don't know if it's gonna
work like but I'm reading all this
interesting science about it and people
have been fasting for thousands of years
and I don't know I'm gonna give it a
shot yeah we'd be like oh okay right it
was more and back me up so but I'm not
out on a limb here it was more that you
came in and you were like this this is
this is going to work and if you got and
the implication was if you guys eat
something today that's crazy you
shouldn't be eating now see that was you
getting defensive and thinking that I
was judging you on what you were eating
and I wasn't because I I think that okay
here's how I'll back you up the [__] man
like you're you're you're the one like
you're accusing me of getting defensive
you're the one yeah like I never said
[__] about what you were eating I was
doing my thing and you were constantly
commenting on it do you understand can
you can you step outside of how upset
you are right now and just can you
understand what it is you're [__]
gaslighting the [__] out of it no no I'm
really not I'm just gaslighting me I'm
just trying to get you to see your feet
and gaslighting I'm Charlie get in there
I'm really I'm a little lost but that's
what happens only because
yeah yeah they're but I understand both
sides of it you know you always do how
about this I'll start with this I'm open
to hearing
what you see I'm open to hearing what my
culpability is in this misunderstanding
can you
tell me what what it is and I'll listen
to it and I'll and I'll try to respect
uh it's it's just that uh the the
feeling that I'm getting or the the
implication that I'm getting
I can't ever use the word implications
uh is that
I get so into doing a thing and then I
judge other people for not doing ah or
that I'm like this is the way and if
you're not doing it that's that's the
thing that I don't ever really remember
doing I do remember getting you know
very adamant about like
you know I I do believe this is gonna
work I don't think you can do something
that extreme without thinking like on
some level like I think that's what's so
Rob's point that he that he's trying to
make uh is if I may sure is uh is I
think what sometimes we found funny
about it is it's definitely funny is
your confidence in it right yeah so just
like you're just talking about the oils
or or vegetables yeah that that you that
you would
have these things that you'd read like
The Master Cleanse yeah yeah and you
would approach it with such confidence
and conviction and convince Clarity and
like I think because
not recognizing the irony that things
are constantly changing
yeah I got you pseudoscience and Science
and so that would then we didn't hear
about it for years and then when we'd
say hey what about that master cleanse
and you were like that that was [__]
[__] and then we'd be like whoa like
that was such a big swing and it and I I
hear what you're saying in terms of like
once it seems like I'm I'm projecting
some kind of judgment that's that that
doesn't feel good I'm not judging how
how you looked at
I'm not I never felt like that I was
being judged sorry good it was more okay
because I I that was the impression I
was getting was that you were you were
you know sort of that you got the
impression that I was coming in being
like well because I mean you said it you
were like what you're eating yeah I was
using I was using that as an example not
of judgment I was using it as an example
of an extreme point of view yeah that
all I'm trying to point all I was
pointing out is like the implication is
that what I'm eating is going going to
destroy me because of how passionate you
are about not eating what I mean yes
yeah and you're saying don't yuck my yum
and we're saying yours is no yum because
you're not eating food well I think the
thing that I take a little bit about was
that I had this like that my conviction
was so like my if there was any
conviction it was like I find this
fascinating and I want to try this like
because I because I'm constantly seeking
trying to feel better it's a little jab
and you're fine with a jab but where you
take Umbridge or you get defensive and
this is understandable is when the jab
starts to say I know this is a fact
about you and you're like well wait wait
it feels like I'm being you're like I'm
the authority on me let me speak for me
thankfully uh I I don't I don't do real
I don't live in the extremes quite as
much anymore although I do still gobble
up all the knowledge I like it but I
don't really remember it
you know what I mean I remember bits and
pieces like I remember the you know like
I remember the application of it but
it's like if you were to ask me like why
do you take quercetin I'm like I don't
remember it works for you and also I you
know then you get can get into some sort
of existential sort of thinking which is
like
you may be destined to have this
approach to your life and incapable of
taking say your approach or my Approach
that like you're hardwired into this is
you're just going to be doing this no
matter what for the rest of your life
different diets experimenting on
different ways of eating food and that's
just possibly going to be your your path
in this life I don't know
it could be but then every once in a
while you gotta have pizza and chicken
wings which I did last night yeah good
and it made me feel I'm glad you are you
seem more balanced when you're in that
zone than when you're in a really dialed
oh for sure for sure yeah yeah I know I
don't think it's I think it's like
because like the mental side of it you
have to pay attention to too right so if
you're if you're so mentally fixated on
and and you know like rigid about what
it is that you're doing that's not
that's not healthy mentally Mara how are
you feeling about your decision to sit
in today uh this is riveting
wow we will be yeah yeah we've cut a lot
of that already I'm lost I feel like
this is what but maybe it's just like
what I'm interested in I don't know like
maybe you gotta have both things I think
the fans are scared that Rob and Glenn
are on the verge of breaking up but
they're not that fascinating so that's
really fascinating do people not
navigate conflict on the basis no they
don't not like read it they don't no
they they really don't dude
learn how do you have a capacity
for conflict that other people just
don't have and I think it's what makes
you successful is you're okay you're
totally comfortable navigating conflict
you don't see conflict you you don't
conflate conflict with uh negativity
right or or negative outcomes you
conflate conflict with a positive
outcome and I think a lot of people
avoid conflict because it does get
uncomfortable uncomfortable for people
I grew up in a household where uh
conflict was not really something that
was navigated right so I had to learn
and I actually have credited you in my
life like with Jill for helping me learn
how to navigate conflict and helping me
learn not to conflate conflict with
negative outcomes or
or
um
you know that conflict is inherently bad
right in the same way that like I had to
sort of teach myself the difference
between confidence and arrogance because
I think it's easy to conflate those
things too right like and there is a
massive difference and I do think that
like I think conflict is is crucial in
in a in a friendship in a marriage in a
relationship to be able to navigate
conflict to be able to have conflict and
not have it be and not like you know
have it be like oh this person disagrees
with me or that I'm being misrepresented
and therefore I categorically can't be
their friend or their you know uh spouse
anymore it takes practice it's not it's
not it's always uncomfortable it's not
like something you anybody seeks out
yeah but but I don't know like well I
think it's on some level you do because
I think you enjoy it uh but I think well
I enjoy solving an emotional problem or
distance but yes but I don't enjoy I
don't like no you don't want to make
people feel bad that's not what I mean I
don't mean to imply that I just mean you
like debate you like debate likes yeah
and I think I think interesting
conclusions come out of conflict right
you change somebody else's mind about
something you change your own mind about
something right you're you're working
through stuff it's the only way to
really work through stuff is that well
there's a you know not to steer to the
show we don't have to go into the show
but like I do feel like when we are at
our best is when we have navigated an
episode that we have been conflicted
about yes and we have pulled something
out from each other that we don't
naturally go to or have and we have
forced each other to go to that place
and it makes it more well-rounded better
episode of Television yeah I agree as
you said like you know the the comedy
Voltron of it is such that often you
have a very strong point of view about
how something should go what a joke
should be what a story point should be
and so do you
and sometimes they're the same and
that's easy that's fine most of the time
probably I think yeah most Yes actually
that's true yeah and then when it isn't
it's like you guys are kind of battling
it out and I'm usually sort of going
like okay yeah yeah you know what maybe
maybe we take some of that and some of
that and there's a way to go so
interesting is when it isn't and then we
we force it through whatever lens it
goes through and then it becomes the
thing that the three of us all agree on
so that you know we're in the editing
room knowing now you're cutting it wrong
it should be this right like so it
becomes a thing that we all
have a mutual Vision on usually there's
not usually a ton of arguments by the
time we get to the editing room
um and even now like the arguments don't
don't don't take on the same sort of
intensity that they used to in the in
the early days but I never felt like
conflict that felt like creative
searching you know conflict feels a
little bit more like this conversation
about a personality trait yeah yeah
but either way no matter what it's it's
never comfortable you don't seek it out
but it but also you never whenever you
hear about you know movies that had or
television shows that had you know it
was just so fun and everything was easy
and then you watch it and you're like
yeah this Show's not that the show's not
that good the movie sucks or some of the
best reason of course like the best just
thought all the [__] time or or just
the fact that they're tortured
emotionally which allows them to access
creative parts of their brain that but
and also like the greatest and strongest
relationships that you have in your life
are with people that you are that you
have insane amounts of conflict with
yeah for sure hopefully you you navigate
those yeah I'll bet you a one of our
highest rated episodes of the podcast
the more people would listen to
would be an episode where the three of
us of the four of us picked our favorite
episodes and then fought as to why yeah
this is the best episode of sunny and
you are wrong and you are wrong and I'm
gonna plead my case and it doesn't have
to get personal but the more convicted
you are in your position the more
interesting it is
[Music]
hell for all you New York and Philly
creeps we've got some great news for you
we are bringing you the Always Sunny
podcast live Billy we will see you at
the Mann Music Center September 23rd and
New York City we're gonna see you on
October 12th at Radio City Music Hall
head to the always sunnypod.com now for
more details and ticket info do not wait
to get tickets they will sell out oh
yeah see you there
this show is sponsored by better help
that's right Charlie better help is an
online therapy service that is designed
to be convenient affordable and suited
to your schedule have you tried therapy
lately have you been thinking about
trying to try it yeah I mean it's easy
to find reasons not to dive in and do it
you know one of which being that you're
just you're just too busy right which is
something I think we can all relate to
right yeah oh yeah sorry I'd like to
unpack all my childhood trauma but I
gotta go to a brunch oh
a brunch okay that doesn't feel like
good enough reason you know too often we
get caught up in doing things that make
others happy when sometimes what you
really need is to do to stop and just
take take a moment to think about your
own needs you know otherwise
you're left feeling stretched a little
too thin right and you're burned out and
to be clear therapy is not just helpful
for people dealing with major or minor
traumas therapy is a useful tool for
anyone interested in examining their
life and learning coping strategies to
live it more better yes that's exactly
right live a more better life with
better help but don't just take our word
for it take bags
you know what she's probably off getting
better help again oh yeah oh yes Meg
loves better help she loves it she
always says that it's been super helpful
for her when she needs it and I know
that she's mentioned that it's helped
her set boundaries and deal with making
tough choices in work and in her
personal life yeah actually all you got
to do is you got to fill out a brief
questionnaire you know to get matched
with a licensed therapist and then guess
what if you don't end up clicking with
that person you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge
find more balance
with better help yeah you know visit
betterhelp.com Sunny to get 10 off your
first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash sunny
foreign
because it was about it was just about
you guys's inner personal Dynamics by
the way I was watching it being like
okay we took both these characters in
this direction for the rest of the show
after this episode yeah
um it's it's also just I don't know if
you guys are feeling this watching it
too but it's wall-to-wall jokes
it's never not being funny like there's
like you know what I mean even like the
only thing that and even this is funny
because of how not funny we played it
but like when
we get into the when I come back from
the video store with Transporter 2 and
we get into like it's it's sort of
overtly comedic at first and then it and
then it just turns into like a real
relationship yes like it turns into it
and we don't play and we play it like we
I remember I was talking about this
other day like this is gonna be funnier
if we play it like uh like a drama yeah
yeah yeah we have that scene transcribed
if you guys wanna actually act it out I
think that like from a performance
standpoint that episode is really
interesting because it is played mostly
like a drama and and not going hard at
last and then there are so many laughs
throughout just with what you're talking
about like the apple seeds and the apple
skin and just incredible
apples for you he doesn't like for me to
eat the apples with the skin on it he
says his Skin's loaded with toxins okay
well good news max not here I know he's
not here and that's why I need you to do
it for me please please oh Jesus just
eat it with the skin I do not like it
with the skin D I'm not allowed to eat
it with the skin I'm not allowed oh my
God all right it's just a whole episode
about like massive codependency too you
know just just just
it's simply about how we all relate to
one another and then the conflict within
but it is so
low stakes like uh scheme plot wise you
know there's no big like what's Heist it
it's high emotional steaks yeah there's
no story really there's no wacky
[Laughter]
but not really what you really want yeah
what I really want is uh well I I a
friendship companionship yeah you know
someone to watch a movie with yeah have
you guys ever had a dramatic friend
breakup
in your real life static friend I've
been had
dramatic when I hear your poem your your
thing with this because I think like
any friendships that that felt like they
weren't working for me I just would try
to figure out how to make them fizzle
out you know I was never comfortable
going to a friend and being like I don't
you know in some some form of I don't
want to I don't think we should be
friends anymore right
I see this more
um not to generalize I'm actually
speaking of like specific people in my
life but I I I find that women tend to
have big blow-ups for and like
friendships and way more than men
whereas men will just like stop hanging
out yeah yeah right it just ends it just
ends and there's not like a there's not
as much
drama behind it right you know but it
depends on the guy like I have some male
friends that I know that do have those
blow-ups and always are having tension
with one another and I'm always like oh
that's interesting it's never it's not
me but like uh
certain people I know in my friend group
I'm like wow they're always kind of
having to fall out with this other
person and they are having those things
where was this episode based on a
friendship breakup like do you guys
remember conceptualizing this episode
and how it came about I don't I remember
I remember somebody start with the cat
with a cat in the morning and it built
out from there and it built out from
there yeah I'm kind of in the middle of
something with my cat right now oh okay
well yeah I like cats let's bring him
into the mix uh can't do that he is in
the wall somewhere
he's in the wall yeah I think he got
into the wall wow I think it started
with you guys breaking up I feel like we
someone pitched that that was a funny
ice boat yeah it was both because what
we often do is we'll have like okay cat
no wall that's a card right and then Mac
and Dennis break up that's a card and
then we're looking at it and we realize
like well what if that's the same you
know story
which is kind of a fun thing like
because it's the two don't inherently
have anything to do with each other but
here's one thing I remember finding so
funny on on the day when we were filming
it but I don't remember if it was in the
script or if we were just pitching it to
you is is you is me telling you that I'm
coming over and you telling Caitlin
Charlie's coming over and her saying I
don't care and then you having to
resigned and say yeah I don't care
either yeah that was an on the day thing
it was right yeah yes that was not in
the script I remember finding that so
there's a lot of money a lot of martyr
and Roselle in here that Martin
Roselle's all over skin toxins feels
like those guys yeah totally I love when
you call
um you're you're talking to Charlie or
when you go it's what he does it's what
he does that's what he does and the cold
opened too like calling Caitlin a cat
lady and then the way you guys walk out
with your hands
it's because we had we were doing a
whole other bit that got cut I think
that's a Big Trouble in Little China oh
it was big trouble that's what we're
doing yeah the guy with the hat the guy
yeah what season is The Gang dines out
it's a couple Seasons nine right nine I
believe it's nine up to nine okay
because that's going back into that
dynamic between the two of you guys
which is so fun yeah this is a romantic
comedy yeah this is a romantic concept
yes but like it's the and we we got to
do both you know we have to do the big
episodes and we got to go to the water
park and those episodes are great
um but man when we can key in on little
things that feel real like Frank cuts
his toes with a knife you know Jesus
Christ Frank are you cutting your
toenails with a steak Knife I suppose
you have a problem with that too
I botched that one oh that's a botched
job it's so funny because it's so
intimate and you're getting such like a
close look at the characters and you're
kind of peeling away a curtain that no
one had seen before and we didn't know
that Mac Dennis had this movie night and
that you know
that their relationship was here yet you
know so I don't know I found this one
amazing yeah the scene at the end where
we get where we're uh at the restaurant
together and we're making up you
remember where we shot that for some
reason I I thought it was in Philly but
that was a different episode when we
were in the Barnes the Dave and Busters
no we shot that at Dave and Buster that
was Dave and Buster's yeah okay that was
Dave and Buster's it was like a side
like dining room yes or whatever so
again yeah what was the episode where we
ended with by
oh with The Predator with The Predator
was that this then that we didn't wind
up putting it in the show
[__] dude yes yes it was okay that's why
it was it was in this episode it was in
that scene yeah which would make sense
because that's it you wanted to watch
Predator yeah
and like a close-up on our bicep yeah
yeah because that's what it is so okay
so I was watching it I was like oh did
we shot this in Dave and Busters oh no
we didn't because we ended that scene
but with us uh-huh but we didn't wind up
using it we didn't wind up using it I
wonder why we cut that out it probably
seems like style wise different for the
rest of the episode is so sort of
natural you know from a camera
standpoint yeah it's just very like
maybe it felt like a hat on a hat like
it's just like another joke yeah like
there's not a lot of like push-ins or
anything in this episode like so it
might have felt weird to just do such a
very stylistic thing at that point or
maybe it just wasn't funny maybe we cut
it we're like ah it's not that funny
it's not that funny maybe we thought
about it maybe maybe we were like that's
got to go in you were like no it's got
to go out maybe we did it's possible
maybe we did and see you don't remember
that part all we remember is how close
we are
yeah man
and that we belong together
let's do it
who is it in uh in in Predator that it's
it's obviously Schwarzenegger and it's
uh Colorado weathers is it weathers yeah
definitely it's not just it's not Jesse
The Body Ventura no I think it's Carl
Weathers that's that's a Carl Weathers
is that right before is that right after
he said you son of a [__] yeah glad he
comes in right you think they're gonna
get in a fight yeah right and then it's
like nah
that's great so good so good yeah uh so
a few episodes ago you guys asked the
creeps to send us like Sunny continuity
errors did you notice the major one in
this episode yeah yeah oh yeah it's in
that same dining scene yeah we have that
scene if you guys want to watch it oh
you're staying on your water stain on
your shirt
[Music]
all right the big breasted woman yes
Mac is very straight in this episode
well ish I mean you were very in love
with Dennis
what is he told that would be meeting a
woman with giant breasts I was also told
that I was to meet a woman with giant
breasts yes Geniuses I set you up now
can you please make up because you're
driving everyone crazy
look I'm sorry that I called you
codependent okay I think you have a
great friendship and It's Perfectly
Natural for two grown men to need each
other this badly so make up please
shut up hi all right okay oh my God you
know what see this is that shorthand I
don't care anymore guess what we are
making up this is how we make it okay so
makeup don't make up kill each other
we're in the process of making up yeah
right now
yeah I know what you need you know what
I mean
yeah yeah you're not ready to admit it
that's the thing like there's an olive
branch today
did you make yourself throw up
I tried but I couldn't
smoke some cigarettes
the smoke will suffocate the bacteria
definitely a Roselle joke yeah
yeah oh it's Charlie's you know what you
do a little thing in this in this
episode in a different scene where
you're yelling at do you about not being
allowed to eat the apple which is such a
funny thing and then she says fine I'll
peel you the apple and your little smile
and then you throw that
well I got my way you got your way yeah
yeah yeah yeah well uh the I believe
when Danny was using the toe knife the
line I scripted was oh I botched it I
botched it and he didn't get that line
right but he came a box box job a
botched job no that was that was me that
was you yeah did you tell him to say
that no no it's well I don't know if it
was in the script or not but uh I just I
botched it was in the script because I
remember there's a big Roselle thing
about like botching something no no no
no that was me really that was me yeah
because because I know the reason I know
is because that's like uh that's like a
thing
uh that my dad used to say all the time
like I botched it like he would say I
don't know if that was just and I just
remember thinking that was really that
was really funny but uh yeah so I don't
remember a Bots job it's a box job yeah
it's very yeah that's something my dad
would say like so that's a botch job
um
Danny also in this episode instead of
saying my head is spinning he says my
head is swimming yeah yeah wait who
sorry who says that Frank
hey uh
he gets tired of Mac telling him all
these things like I gotta get out of
here my head is swimming yeah
which is just a boss job of the line but
you know it's a better life it also kind
of works yeah totally my head is
swimming is that not a thing can you not
say that like my head is we're swimming
with ideas yeah I guess you could is
that a thing
I think so I think that's an expression
how did The Cat In The Wall come about
that con did that happen to someone I
was trying to make that happen to
somebody it did it happen to somebody
maybe it was sunny Lee I feel like it
was either Pat or sunny yeah I came in
with that cat in the wall yeah yeah
I remember being irritated on the day
about how wide the wall was that the
wall when we break the hole in should
have been half the depth Oh you mean
that there was too much room for her to
climb it yeah well yeah like like
there's too much room for her to climb
in it's too thick a wall like yeah yeah
that really Jimmy in sideways with
barely enough room yeah but what are you
gonna do I love that that's what you did
that that was your a lot of cat work on
Sunny a lot of cats are funny cats are
funny dogs are funny you know uh birds
are funny people can relate to them
because they have cats yeah yeah whole
episodes about an iguana you can't
really relate yeah I don't know she lost
her iguana it's funny but I don't know
it's actually not a bad idea it's not
bad Dee gets an iguana put it on the
board it was up on the board
um so Mac tries to go over uh to like
take things over at Charlie and Frank
Frank's Place have you guys ever had
like a controlling roommate that kind of
made you crazy I I this is probably
based on me I mean you like your
frustration with me as a roommate no
like no not as roommate as a partner
like coming in I think the joke was that
this it's my character but it's like
partially me like coming in and being
like well now we're gonna do it the way
that I want to do it and I just keep
like yeah
telling Frank and Charlie the way that
they're gonna live and there's like some
benefit to that but mostly I'm just a
pushy [__] do you remember kind of
conversations about the Cheeto fingers
on the wall
we were I believe that this is a product
yes it is
like loves the Cheeto finger thing like
they wanted it right wasn't that
boy they were like
I think it was the opposite it was that
they didn't want that was what they
didn't want it was like that's the one
thing about it that makes more sense but
for some reason I remember them being
like and if you could really talk about
the Cheeto fingers
maybe yeah yeah we got a little plug
from Cheetos that was fine it felt like
easy to do yeah yeah well that's one of
those things where like it's it's less
distracting if it's somebody's holding a
bag of Cheetos then something that you
know is like a knockoff thing yeah
clearly a movie brand or whatever
but again
we didn't get any of that money that
went straight to the network it did but
it was it was helping justify why they
kept picking the show sure because at
this point still no one was watching it
and did the brand to you guys are you
guys like how did it come about the
network and then it trickles down to us
at some point while we're writing that
they're like hey just so you know if you
could work in Cheetos or something it
would be good for the show we're like
yeah all right we got to do that on this
show what
yeah did you have one today I had one
this morning yeah I got up at 5am
is there uh I want to try that I want to
try one try one we should do it on the
Pod and you should talk about how you
feel you should take a feel free and
talk about it I mean I should drive like
a vintage Mercedes around and just see
like what like you know like how does it
handle you know how does it you know put
the top down okay big one that's a big
ass that's comfortable yeah yeah these
shoes they're just oh yeah hey everybody
MTV's Michael Jordan listen uh robots do
you guys remember video stores oh yeah
right Blockbusters I'm so petty okay
that the day that Blockbuster announced
bankruptcy was I was elated I I hated
Blockbuster with a passion why'd you
hate Blockbuster because Blockbuster
would not carry it's a fire If It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia oh why it
does not carry Sunny oh [__] them they
did not carry it [__] man what was
why um
too edgy don't know don't know we kept
getting the run around but we would go
uh I love I loved going to Blockbuster I
love I love renting movies the the
just the whole uh event of going to the
movie store totally so exciting
especially like you if you got to know
the person there
they were they were film Buffs they were
the videos yeah like that's why they
wanted that job you know they were like
Quentin Tarantino's in the making yeah
they were all Quentin Tarantino's they
just couldn't write like him yeah
uh like I remember in New York I would
go to the one just like walk up the
street I had the little car that you get
the stamp on every time you rent so like
if you get enough space one free one
yeah and just sometimes the person would
suggest movies and you would take it
home you'd watch it and like I'm so glad
this person suggested this movie I would
have never found this otherwise yeah
yeah then they invented the Internet
ruined everything totally then the
internet ruined everything yeah they'd
have like 21 copies of the new release
and you'd like one and then they'd all
be gone you're like no go to the front
desk like are there any back here yeah
it did create a sense of anticipation
and it made it an event and then you had
to if you missed out you had to wait
until the following weekend of having a
thing like in my hands that you could
like you know open it up and like there
were sometimes see yeah cool artwork or
you'd be like oh look there's this one
has DVD extras and people talk about
like the the choices and scrolling and
sometimes you get caught in that
in that Vortex where you're just
scrolling through and not choosing
something that that would happen in
Blockbuster too oh yeah you would just
walk around option paralysis no yeah but
for some reason it was more exciting and
then if your dad if your mom or dad let
you get all three you know what I mean
you'd be like can we just get them all
you know what I mean keep them for you
yes
did you guys have one movie that you
rented like over and over again that you
can remember oh uh definitely the
nightmare in Elm Street movies those are
I rented those over and over and over I
was obsessed with those movies I don't
know why because they gave me now do you
ever have a memory of a movie that you
would see every time you were in there
and you'd think maybe I'll get that but
oh yes gonna get it and you did it like
50 times do you remember what movie I
was these honor are you [__] kidding
me no way no are you serious or do you
remember me saying that to you one time
I feel like this no I remember that we
may have had that yeah no I remember I
remember that that it's possible that
we've had this conversation before but
if we yeah we did have this conversation
okay yeah but I do but I do
just so happened that that was same
movie but that is one of those what did
you say but I think it resonated because
that was one of those movies that like
and I've never seen it no I've never
seen it I don't even I I don't even know
who's in it anymore like I don't even
remember I think Jack Nicholson is in it
sure yeah but but that is one of those
movies that I saw like a million times
and just never he's on the cover you're
like maybe never grabbed it that blew my
mind there for a second but yeah
I have this conversation we may have had
it on the podcast do you guys remember
at becoming the age where you're
starting to be more sexual right and
then you're like you're in the
Blockbuster you're like do you think we
could get like porgies or whatever like
you know like uh like
maybe okay we'll definitely rent the one
that our parents know that we're allowed
to rent but like maybe we could like
slip in a Porky's yes
switch to DVDs
I remember that you know probably like
20 years old or something like that I
don't remember I mean I watched a lot of
horror films like back in those days so
like I feel like there was always there
was always that in in horror movies
horror films I watched X so I saw Pearl
first and then I saw X is Pearl a
prequel yes but it seemed like you
needed to see Pearl to to understand X
but that's just the way I saw it anyway
I loved them both just like transporter
yeah you can't transport straight to the
second one I wonder if that well you
know what I think maybe that came from
the fact that I remember actually that I
did do that I watched Transporter 2 and
I'd never seen transporter and I
remember thinking like am I gonna be
lost yeah yeah and then realizing almost
immediately like that's ridiculous I'm
sure I won't be lost I'm gonna bet you
can watch any Jason Statham movie across
his entire catalog and not be lost and
not be lost yeah as long as he's in it
sure you'll be fine yeah
[Music]
man it's finally summer everything
slowed down here with a strike and I am
itching to get out of Dodge and take a
trip how nice man where are you thinking
about going I don't know boy have I got
the destination for you now have you
guys ever heard of a place called
Philadelphia Pennsylvania show it to me
on a map
um Sun's made up no uh it's funny but
you know we've been to Philly so many
times but we're always so busy shooting
I don't think I don't think we you know
so we don't ever have enough time just
get out there and explore and what I'd
like to do really is Trek around and
make some more memories you know but I
you know where to start oh dude I've got
just the thing for you have you tried
Viator you got to get on viatoric it's a
website an app to book travel
experiences all right they they have a
ton of unique options they're all all
over the map they have over 300 000
bookable experiences in 190 countries
I'm looking at Viator for Philly and
they have a bunch of cool looking tours
you got a walking tour a cruise tour a
trolley tour where you can get hammered
while you ride even something described
as a dark Philly adult night tour oh now
that sounds like an extreme Adventure
yeah that sounds cool yeah sexy guest
ghost tour
now I used Viator recently uh with Jill
uh we took a trip to Hawaii and we used
Vitor for that and uh it was awesome you
know we did a we did a did a night
snorkel and let me tell you have you
guys ever done a night snorkel it's
awesome it was it was really trippy at
night like you know we loved it plus you
know we got 10 off our uh vacation with
the Viator 10. and they have free
cancellation payment options and 24 7
service
so you can always be flexible yeah and
viator's travel experiences have
millions of real traveler reviews so you
can check out what others thought of the
activities that you're most interested
in download the Viator app now and use
code viator10 for 10 off your first
booking one app over 300 000 experiences
you'll remember do more with Viator
[Music]
well did we do it
probably covered it you know
that's probably yeah anything else about
are you guys breaking up or are you
staying together I think we'll stay
together I mean we'll stay together
friendships are a complicated thing you
know they're uh
they're a living thing I do think you
guys should do the scene just because
it's so iconic the fans love it okay
fans love it let's do it for the fans
okay perfect all right hello yo
uh where you been
uh what do you mean man I I uh you know
what actually why don't you guys switch
so then that way
I could just cut between these two
cameras you know because my looks to him
aren't gonna be good my looks to him
aren't gonna be good you know what I
mean okay
[Laughter]
okay he's gonna text me about it later
oh no I'm sorry Charles take a big crap
all right here we go all right hey
where you been
uh what do you mean I was getting the
movie
uh yeah but you you and you weren't
answering any of my calls I've been sort
of calling you overnight yeah I was
having a conversation with the video
store clerk uh yeah but I texted you
9-1-1 dude that means it's an emergency
yeah yeah I saw that what was the
emergency Mack
well I couldn't get in touch with you
dude I almost called the police
the emergency was you couldn't get in
touch with me I mean that's a little bit
of an overreaction don't you think man
like
uh I was gone for what an hour I mean
well yeah but I thought we had a deal
you know
with me every once in a while and then
that way I would know that you're okay
I'm okay can we watch the movie
yeah great sure
okay
all right good
transported too
yeah yeah I I look man I you know I I
know you wanted to see Predator again
but I feel like you know we've seen that
like 30 times in the last two months and
I thought maybe we could mix things up
you know video store clerk guy said that
this movie was was awesome so
the video store clerk guy I feel like
you you won't stop talking about him
[Laughter]
that was a good time
let's use that one okay
and I asked him for a movie
recommendation okay yeah you got one
[Laughter]
it's really not that big of a deal dude
well the big deal Dennis is that I
wasn't even consultant on the decision
okay
this is a big deal to me as well you
know it's also my night plus transporter
two we haven't seen transporter one
which means we'll be completely lost I
doubt it plus Jason Statham's physique
is nothing like the lineup will you stop
I don't want to hear conversations
anymore about dudes physiques and
whether or not they can body mass alone
okay that that's
yes okay yeah I get it okay can we not
that's what I was trying to avoid okay
I don't want to have a conversation
about body mass okay we've had that
conversation five times you know a day
for the last month because we keep
watching predator and all you want to
talk about is weathers and and you know
Jesse The Body Ventura and how many
pounds they can pack on and why that's
important it's important to pack on mass
so we're talking about carbo loading I
don't want I don't I don't want to have
this conversation oh no I don't want to
have this conversation I just don't man
uh I don't you had to say I don't want
to have this question I don't have this
conversation with you anymore no you'd
rather have it with the video store
clerk
you know what man I look if you don't
want to watch the movie with me that's
fine I'll watch it by myself God damn
whoa Jesus where's this coming from
I guess I I have been thinking a lot
about what Dee said and I do think
I do think that maybe we are spending a
little too much
you had it I know yeah
I just I do think we're we are spending
a little too much time together
I can't look at you
well what are you saying
I'm just I feel like okay
I'm saying that I feel like we're in a
little bit of a rut
and I feel like that I'm not
flourishing
[Laughter]
wow
far be it for me to keep the flower of
you from flourishing
I guess I'll grab my [__] and stay
Charlie's but wait don't do that
I mean I
I feel like I'm the one that got us into
this mess okay so you'll stay Charlie no
sorry give me that again
okay so you'll stay at church no
I can't
no you should stay there because you Pro
you said you already said that you would
and I and I and also I have more stuff
and it's gonna take me longer to pack
and I think it just it'll be easier so
you should yeah
bing bong
what
what was that
police officer
hi I'm responding to a missing person
missing persons report
um
is the line
is the line uh
something that was caught me and I feel
like it caught me today when I watched
it too
when you stop him
do you say no don't do that when he says
he's gonna go stay at Charlie's is that
what we're script is yes yes I I and I
think and I think the idea was it was
like no don't do that it's not it's not
your fault you shouldn't have to do it
and then the reality of having to stay
at Charlie's hits me like well so you'll
stay at Charlie's no like you know like
no no uh no you're right no yeah no no
you didn't let me finish don't don't do
that right now give yourself five ten
minutes yeah yeah yeah five ten minutes
to cool down cool down and then pack
your bag and then pack your bag
well it was a good take fellas it was a
good episode
it's a great episode I I it really is
wall-to-wall jokes I I encourage people
to go back and watch this unlike this
podcast which was not yelled walls are
different than sitcoms this is our
podcast is not a situation comedy it is
and if it was a slice of conversation
especially it's an interesting
conversation an interesting conversation
for the kids at home well thanks for
thanks for sitting in Mara thank you
guys do you feel like you you were happy
you did it or you're like God damn what
I do that why did I guys I'll take any
minute I can be with the three of you oh
that's true
they like spending time with you as well
you guys are the best
thank you